and they didn't warn you of any of this
before no they haven't I also have
osteoporosis and scoliosis because of um
not having the right hormones I guess or
not having enough hormones in my body so
my back hurts I still have to at some
point remove my breasts because
um you know you're not supposed to have
this best implants what the hell did I
do what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to the sit down where I have on
different guests from different walks of
life and you know we go through
different cultural and conservative
topics so today
um I actually have a guest um that goes
by the name of shapeshifter on YouTube
and you um you went through a transition
surgery and you ended up regretting it
that's right
um yeah I agree with my whole transition
which is a surgery because
um
even when I started taking estrogen it
really messed up with my mind and made
my mental health worse but at the time I
attributed it to the idea that I still
like need more surgeries more biting
modifications to become true self and so
yeah unfortunately I had the sex change
surgery quote unquote sections right
back then that's what it was called now
it's called gender confirmation surgery
which is like what
um yeah it's all I regret it I wish I
could take it back but there is no way
of going back to sort of completely
irreversible surgeries yeah even taking
testosterone artificially is not the
same as having like a healthy genitals
and having gone at to regulate your
natural hormones once you mess up your
appendicism you just don't know what's
going to happen you're opening Pandora's
box right and we still don't know how
like hormones affects our entire bodies
you know in trans Community people are
doing things for aesthetic purposes and
completely often overlooking how
delicate our bodies are while you know
testosterone estrogen has its own
purposes Beyond just Aesthetics
and I wish I gotten more information
about that before signing up for this by
the at the time I was brainwashed by the
community and once I found trans
identities there was just this notion
that if you don't transition you're at
higher risk of self-cancellation because
I was struggling with mental health I
saw that I must do this or made athletic
kind of self-harm and it just was really
how transition super quick how old were
you um when you first got it like got
the idea of like gender changing surgery
I was like 21 22 so I was 18 plus but to
be honest like when you're that age you
feel like you know everything but you
surely don't you still have a whole life
ahead of you and I think that was a huge
mistake uh because I thought my feelings
would never change about wow wait I must
become a woman but since they change and
I had my sex change surgery at 24 so I
was transitioned pretty quick I remember
I was approached to the surgery it's
just like in nine months
um which is not enough mental health
therapy to get approved for something so
life-changing and before that I've never
gotten any mental health so the first
time I've gotten it was when I went to
get you know letters for the surgery and
I didn't realize I had all the trauma
from childhood and all the issues till
later in my life because I thought like
you know I had ADHD and gender identity
disorder I didn't know I had personality
disorders I didn't know how like uh PTSD
due to like traumatic childhood
um due to bullying and Essay so I never
even knew like those issues could have
possibly contributed to the way I felt
about my body about my reality I just
wish I was left as this and I wish I was
given the time to mature and into my
manhood I know it's weird to say but
um I think anything would have been
better than cutting off generals
honestly looking back at it I was very
deluded thinking like allowing people to
knock me out on anesthesia and Cuddles
like my peanuts like that's crazy
but yeah I just woke up maybe two years
ago and I was like what the hell did I
do right what because I kind of wanna I
kind of want to go through like what
like because I as someone who like I was
a tomboy growing up a bit
um
I I've never understood like wanting to
be the opposite gender so when you said
like childhood issues like what what
sort of issues do people have in
childhood that typically leads them to
want to be the opposite gender
um yeah I sing with me I'm just a
naturally very feminine I was very
naturally feminine boy initially my
childhood was okay but I think once
um I realized like my classmates are
going to puberty and all that I guess
they started noticing that I was too
feminine for an average boy and so did
my parents you know as I was getting
bullied at school for my femininity that
I couldn't change early
um and um even my parents my own dad
like at some point told me that I'm not
a real man because I'm too emotional and
too sensitive and you know they tried to
Butch me up and give me to karate
classes and all that but it was just
cringe because I was not into it I was
getting beat up and I sing it just early
on engraved in my mind that I'm not a
real man real man must be like you know
big tall and masculine I could just see
how envious my mom was of other boys
that were taller and like stronger and
more masculine I could just see that she
was disappointed in me that I was not
sad and I think once I went through
puberty and all that even before that I
knew I was attracted to men I believe
but for people they gotten stronger
because my body got flooded with
testosterone and as quickly I grew up in
a Muslim country predominantly Muslim
country and I quickly realized like it
was not okay to be same-sex attracted
and I was just like at the time I was
religious and I was begging to God
to make me straight but I don't remember
ever having thoughts of like wanting to
be a girl
um you know I just I did like feminine
sayings and I remember putting towels
around my head
uh pretending it's my hair and my mom
told me like don't do that you know
because she even like joked about it
she's like oh you know you people fall
off and I guess shamanic press did it
and um Flash Forward and yeah so little
things like that I was definitely gender
non-conforming but I grew out of it like
I was going into my adolescence and like
really adulthood I was I knew I was a
man I was a gay man and but then you
know when I went to college I started
questioning my gender you know because
people saw that I was you know wearing
gender bending clothes a little bit
we're in a little bit eyeshadow here and
there but I was you know kind of trying
to express myself through closing but
shortly I realized I was getting an MBA
I was getting Masters in Business and I
even got in trouble
um one of my professors was teaching
entrepreneurship he kind of you know
complained to the teams that I was
nursing professionally and quickly I
realized that I was not welcome this
gender non-conforming man besides like
people asking my pronouns and I started
researching you know what that was and I
quickly was convinced that I was a woman
you know because I liked things that
would be considered what women like in
society and because I was in such
conservative like getting such a
conservative degree like accounting and
Masters in Business it was just not
welcome to trust the way I wanted to
dress as a man and still be uh you know
taken seriously so just quickly
solidified lady in my head that I must
transition to be able to have the hair
that I want or be where be able to wear
accessories that I want and I quickly
and I apparently have ocd2s I got
obsessed with the idea of transition and
it kind of like took over my life and I
was just like okay I need to finish all
this and do everything but initially I
didn't want the bottom surgery like sex
assignment surgery because people were
asking me like what are you gonna get
the surgery and I was like no I don't
want to be like other people I just like
being unique and then as I took estrogen
I think it really made me more
delusional know about my biological
reality so I went from being like a
proud trans woman to like okay I am a
woman and I must do the surgeries it
just saw this connection with my
genitals I started hating my genitals it
made me feel like it doesn't belong
there and I quickly you know decided to
have the surgery and they were I fall
under affirmation only model so doing
you know medical health aboliations and
all that it was nothing but affirmation
I did tell them about childhood sexual
abuse that I had at 11 and I I thought
it was consensual because at the time I
was covering up to trauma I saw that if
I in my head pretend that it was
consensual
um it made me feel like maybe I was a
controlled situation but I wasn't I was
raped and they I told them like I had
this situation at 11. was that with a
guy yeah it was was a guy yeah
um so yeah it is kind of sucks that like
a lot of my traumas it starts with my
trauma are men but I'm also attracted to
men so your concile anxiety is kind of
strange for me right to be honest it's
like how do you want to concile God
um well my mom was Source a lot of my
trauma as well but um you know I would
say from because of the sexual abuse it
was from men and I think early on it
just kind of left me feeling very
insecure about what I am who I am my
body which made me a prime target for
more Predators going into my adolescence
and all that so just abuse kept on
happening but at some point it was just
like once I turned into my adulthood it
was kind of self-inflicted at that point
I just kept on attracted people that
were not that great for me it's like
trauma was this just big cycle until you
like recognize that it's happening it's
hard to break part of it so for sure
what happened in my childhood affected
my life choices and how it went down but
I wish a service at least said oh maybe
it's sexual abuse you don't feel
comfortable with your body maybe it's
because you have internalized homophobia
and you just don't want to be gay
because from early on you've been
brainwashed and being gay is abomination
and all that so but when I came out as
Trans in college like people were very
supportive and in my mind it registered
as like gay is horrible and trans is
good and I was excited like Yay I'm
gonna transition I'm not gonna be a gay
boy anymore and be cringy like you know
gender bending so man and um yeah so
when you you so at 21 you start to
question your gender identity and it
slowly goes from I'm dressing I'm
cross-dressing to taking estrogen to
then the surgery
um where did you go when you first
started considering hormones and surgery
um I end up going to Steinway house in
Boston because I live in Massachusetts
and
um that's where I got estrogen I just
want to mention that like when I was
presenting more feminine I knew I was a
man like actually my life was better
because
um I knew what I was you know and I was
going to mail bathroom and people
sometimes would get a little bit
confused and they would like sort of get
startled you know how potentially
wouldn't have a closer look and realize
I wasn't mad but I think as I started
transitioning we take an estrogen my
dysphora actually got worse because I
was always like obsessing on my passing
am I not passing do people read me as a
woman right because they still reading
as a man and it just like got worse
because there's just like not enough
surgeries or drugs you can take well
when um they could be valid when I I
played in a volleyball tournament
recently I was telling you about the
where we had um there were trans people
playing in it and it's almost like they
would do something too masculine and
then they would like hold back on almost
like it's like they it was so like they
would like jump super high or hit really
hard and then they kind of like it's so
it was it's such a weird I don't know
how to describe it but it was almost
like they at first they were like being
themselves and then they're like oh wait
I need to be something else
um and it just kind of reminded me of
what you were saying because at least
when you were a feminine presenting man
it's like that's who you are and you
don't have to like pretend to be
something you're not yeah for sure and
looking back at it actually people say
oh people are just being authentic self
I don't think I was being authentic sub
I was trying to mimic a stereotype of a
woman
that's like exactly what they were like
yeah
yeah honestly yes I am I am like going
through surgery and made myself like a
fortnite version of what man sings a
woman is right and that's because I
wanted to attract like masculine men and
I felt like is it bigger or my movies or
anything else the longer is my hair is a
more like uh you know stereotypically
like
the more I pass the more I'm valid I
guess as a woman but it was all in my
head you know
um one person I followed online recently
so I said you know even they the woman
just wake up being through my nails I
don't need to do like all those extra
steps to pass this woman you know they
just knows everyone works and it just
kind of resonated with me and I think it
was me like even those of our moments
through my transition when I was 100
convinced it was always that doubt in my
head when I went out like to grocery
store you know do people read me still
as a man and I wasn't passing 100 at no
point didn't you know and it's just six
foot zero it honestly destroyed my
confidence in a way when I was gay it
was hard for me to be in the closet
because there is some straight passing
gay men that nobody can tell they're gay
unless they come out as gay with me it
was not an option because I was super
feminine but when I started passing a
little bit you know it was just a way
for me to be in the closet again like or
actually the first time in my life to be
as explosive and it was very toxic it
was very damaging to constantly find
your identity I'm constantly trying to
mask and then people like oh you're so
beautiful how was it like to grow up as
a beautiful girl and it's like I'm dying
inside because it's not true like I
didn't grow up as a beautiful girl and
you can't just like go go around telling
people the whole story so tell me it
just was difficult tell me tell me about
the surgery uh it was brutal like
honestly looking back at it I can't
believe like I signed up for it it was
definitely downplayed the severity of
the surgery in the trans community and
by the doctors doctors told her to lie
to me and they were like oh you can't
tell the difference
uh straight man love
um you know feeling worried penis slash
in your vagina because it's tighter so
they were just telling me is this like
magical sinking story so they caught up
they caught up my penis and they
inverted it and they cut out my scroll
down
um so they went they drilled a whole my
pelvis and they're lined up on the
inside of the new all that they trailed
with the tissue from my genitals I don't
know why they thought it was a good idea
because they take some things that's not
shaped as a tunnel they saw those pieces
of tissue together trying to form a
tunnel and they expected to dilate plus
a song is a dilation situation as not a
big deal dilation is when they insert an
object that looks pretty much like a
dildo trying to keep things open because
you know they're using all those
affirmative words that are sound like
vanilla and nice but in fact the reason
you have to dilate it because your body
is treated as a wound and it's time to
heal it it's something that doesn't
naturally belong on your body it
explains that to me those terms that
would have never said that was a surgery
does it hurt yeah it was for sure
um it hurt a lot
um but you know I was excited about my
future because I thought you know now
I'm a real woman right that's why I was
getting sexier salmon surgery and that
was a harsh part because they serve the
therapist affirmative affirm your
identity the surgeons do the surgery
mule and then you go out in real world
and you realize you still don't pass and
people don't see you as a woman so it
creates additional trauma additional
dissonance with the way Society sees you
and you constantly have to prove your
perceived woman who would you resolve
unto others it's just not a good way to
live and I don't understand what kind of
therapist would do that to someone who
already has like signs of trauma signs
of not having the best quality of life
you kind of like clear them out and like
affirms then you realize like nobody
else firms up does it still hurt like to
this like what health complications do
you have now uh well that didn't end us
there because
um even though I dilated it just kept on
shutting down I had multiple revisions
since I had
um I had another surgery sorry to cut
you but what's a revision because people
watching might not know what that is
yeah so revision is once they open you
back up because I developed my vaginal
stenosis and people don't like me using
that word but that's what I was diagnos
I was with it's when the entrance was
too tight so I was not able to have
candidates of sex which is what I got it
for and I wanted to be able you know to
be penetrated by a man uh especially
diverting estrogen and I got more
delusional I really wanted you know to
be penetrate it that way and yeah shut
down so they opened me back up and
second time once they opened me back up
they didn't even take any tissue from
anywhere in my body so I was just
dilating again on whatever remnants of
my penis were inside of me plus
additional like raw like opening I guess
I was not even covered with any tissue
and then that of course shut down as
well even though I was driving it was
literally a stand inside of me but to
the point that I couldn't repeat
properly because it was conflict I was
determined to keep things open but it
shut down anyway then I had cold
imaginable plus C once they took a piece
of my Sigma and colon and put it inside
of me but that didn't work either
because the place where the cone
attached to the remnants of my penis
guys got scarred down and shut down so
now I have like one inch of opening that
I can use
um I was people don't know what's going
on with my genitals I've been all across
the country it's been all kinds of money
for different consultations with
different surgeons I had MRIs done so
the latest update is that I have one
inch of remnants of my penis then the
colon tissue is still inside of me but
because it has no access to you know to
train because it constantly produces to
Christians uh it has some some of what
my body absorbs and some of it looked
inflamed on MRIs at least I need to have
at least one more surgery to take that
colon piece out and doctors actually
don't know what's going to happen to me
because this is all experimentals you
just haven't done it enough to know like
um even if I choose not to undergo any
more surgeries like that pollen tissue
could keep on getting more inflamed and
at some point I could use collapse and
die possibly from infection like they
don't really know and
and they didn't warn you of any of this
before no they haven't I also have
osteoporosis and scoliosis because of um
not having the right hormone I guess or
not having enough hormones in my body so
my back hurts I still have to at some
point remove my breasts because
um you know you're not supposed to have
this best implants but
um you know my breasts
um are hurting my back even more I I'm
scared of when I was a surgery because
I'll never have my original chest back
I'll always have a linear scars once you
cut into your bodies it will always be a
scar so I just don't even know what my
future holds because I've also been
mentally impaired because of estrogen
now I realize that my brain was meant to
run on testosterone I miss being just
average dude I miss being obsessed about
money and sex and no juice this whole
emotional thing when you get attached to
guys and uh you know you're expecting
them to text you back but they don't and
all that you know is there just yeah I
realized that I was I was meant to be a
man like I was not meant to be whatever
I am right now but there is no going
back you know even taking testosterone
is traumatic because I have a phantom
lip sync going on when I wake up in the
morning and I feel like I have a boner
and I jump and that's very dramatic and
I it's hard to orgasm it's it's hard you
know things are sexier in my head but
when it comes to doing it you know it
was way easier to you know to have those
uh connections with the partner when I
was intact and everything was the way it
was supposed to now they gave me like
modified genitals and it's hard my life
has been I don't know if I'll ever be
able to enjoy certain types of sex
anymore they move my prostate
um into my new vagina so um the way I
used to be able to have sex you know as
the original
um gay sex doesn't feel the same way so
they didn't warn me about any of that as
they didn't know they didn't tell me
they were moving my prostate and it's
just a us you know and um I don't know
where to go from there being on social
media for sure I wanted to list those I
just wanted to live as a woman but then
when I realized I've been harmed I came
forward this is my story like a year and
a half ago when I realized I wasn't
honest a woman and it kind of was like
uh get people saw my story and it helped
a lot of people to not get the surgery
but people are constantly discussing my
genitals online because we're discussing
my relationship and I just realized how
toxic social media is as well you know
people are constantly it's just a toxic
place and it definitely made my mental
health even worse so I've been trying to
stay strong as trying to focus on
positive things that I have in my life
but it is hard sometimes I it's it's
very hard not to have your mind sleep
back into the past
yeah because now it's like um you said
you have osteoporosis what is it yes and
scoliosis the process is when your bones
get brittle because because of not
having the right hormones and enough for
hormones on my body it was not absorbing
calcium properly plus I live in
Massachusetts we don't get as much
vitamin D
um so that made a calcium absorption a
harder and um that's why my bones are
brittle and my spine started curving
that's how it developed scoliosis and if
I don't take
um I don't if I don't take like certain
amount of hormones if I don't take
enough vitamin D you could get worse
um and actually a lot of children that
are being castrated now so you're going
to have those issues as well which is
completely sad
um and also like um I also the years
that I lived as a eunuch you know
without any testoster in my body I just
had no sexual desires so it actually
made me further away from my target
market which was like man
um I just didn't understand them anymore
you know men just wanna you know
um and they want to go back to work
most of them and I stopped understanding
them and it just it was just disconnects
I just went felt like um when I was a
gay mandating other men my life was
easier I understood some better
I thought the exam and now my also my my
brain functionality has changed you know
and I feel like I'm losing my memories
estrogen in men
like if you Google low testosterone in
man like there is all those issues that
I experienced throughout the years my
anxiety was higher I felt like I needed
a man to protect me and provide for me I
was scared to be by myself
um I was having a lot of anxiety it was
hard for me to keep the weight off
because uh it's hard it was estrogen I
was constantly hungry and um
testosterone makes you winners and I
didn't have any sex drive I just pleased
man because I felt like that's what I
needed to do to be in relationships to
be like I didn't enjoy it I went from
being excited being with men to just
like doing good to just get it over with
and then so we can just hold hands and
you know do romantic stuff but the guys
don't want to do sad and the average guy
don't want to do that so so now it's
like when you can you sorry if this is
TMI can you like go to the bathroom and
stuff okay
um well I go to festivals and every time
I go to a festival
it's just a reminder of what I lost
because I could have just been peeing
normally yeah now every time I go to a
public restroom it's disgusting it's
also like I get a lot of urinary tract
infections um you know I can't take
antibiotics every month that's not
sustainable so there is goes uh every
other week I pee a lot I'll pee like 10
times a day which is uncomfortable
um if I have sex with my partner he goes
down on me I definitely it gets
activated so I need to pee a lot like
for a day through afterwards I I love
long-term effects I don't know about
what's going to be you know if I keep on
getting UTIs that's already I'm getting
like that's not good for your kidneys
and stuff but I can pee sitting down
saying God I compete there are some
people there are kind of keys that have
to dilate there you reach her because uh
you know they screwed up their you wish
you're doing the surgery so now they
have to get their future dilated every
year or so that's so painful and now
even if I'm watching and even thinking
is different now because of the effects
of the ass estrogen yeah it's trauma I
realized like I had trauma around my
genitals because of you know abuse and
all that but now also the surgeries that
got compounded you know and um I even
went to a pelvic floor therapy you know
when they were trying to stick diliers
in me and trying to get me to relax but
that was the one part because after all
the surgeries I had around it even going
to a surgeon I was just having all kinds
of tests since they were pouring like
liquids in me shoving camera in me that
was so traumatizing that I was just like
I just lost it I started crying and
nurse legitimately felt bad for me but
they keep on doing the surgeries um I
know one trans woman I don't identify as
trans you know I had to advise the trans
man but um she she like had the surgery
and um she's now put on seven year
waiting lists for revision
um because she also can't have sex and
she's waiting seven years to go to the
surgeon what percent of the people that
transition would you say regret it out
of the people you know um there is no
not enough statistics you know trans
Community is pushing this one percent
narrative that is only one percent
regret and detransition but the way they
calculated it they're just using that so
I'm asking I'm asking from your
anecdotal experience
um obviously they're gonna lie about the
stats but out of like 10 people you know
that did it what percent would you say
regret it um well it's such a big
spectrum because a lot of trans women
don't get the bottom surgery I think
that's because on certain levels they
know their men you know yeah and a lot
of them are in sex work if you go on
Twitter there's plenty of them showing
those are generals you know and only
fans and um so for them it's like a
dating it's a selling point wasn't
dating and only finance a lot of them
those who don't get the bottom surgery
and I mean at that point you just got a
good job barely you know so those are
usual don't regret it you know they're
fine because technicals they still have
a male sex drive and they enjoy it
because they get fetishized by Chasers
they get all the attention
um on social media and all that so those
are not likely to repair and I feel like
people who end up getting the bottom
surgery from what I understand a lot of
some do regret it I can't say
percentages but I feel like majority of
them either regretted or at least regret
just the bottom surgery it's not the
entire transition
um I don't know being a g trans
Community for sure my vision is suited
to seems like a lot I would say
definitely bigger than one percent for
sure I would say at least 10 20 regret
it I mean they keep on comparing the
surgery to knee surgery which is like
are you effing kidding me like how are
you comparing sex or assignment surgery
work the most sensitive part of your
body sliced up to
um you know choose knee surgery which is
more common what do you think about it
um what do you think about the trend of
them um
transitioning children and like putting
them on drugs oh my God no that's
completely unethical because a lot of
those kids are just gonna either go out
of that phase or just gonna end up being
gay I feel like they see second opposite
LGBT a lot of ways
um because in a way I feel like I've
been through medical conversion therapy
um now that I've been through it I think
the president of w pass Marcy Bowers
who's
um double passive standards for
transgender healthcare she admitted on
cameras that boys that are blocked on
pattern stage two will not have an
orgasm how in the world is a radical to
take away orgasm ability from beings
that have not explained that like how
can kids opt out of something basically
they're just like testing on you guys
and then I the last um the transitioner
I interviewed told me that a good
percentage of trans people are autistic
I am autistic too yeah and so I'm like
you're taking
autistic people so off the bat there's
already a mental disorder and you're
just reading them down the path of
transitioning is the solution to your
mental disorder which like and and it
actually it made me really sad because
it's like
um just like growing up I used to like
work with some autistic kids and I'm
just like I can't even imagine like
especially because they get obsessed
with stuff so I'm like yeah
so I'm like if you give them the wrong
rabbit hole and they're always so into
research too and they I know they fake
all the research so it's like if you
give these autistic kids that are
obsessed with research fake research to
that that's like totally skewed and
biased to confirm every like this is the
answer to all their problems I'm like
that is so predatory that even even if
they're over the age of like even if
they're of age it's like I just think
that's wrong that's like giving and
especially like I know a good percentage
are like depressed too and like that
sort of stuff so I'm like that's like
aiding like giving someone a gun when
they have depression I'm like I I just
think it's wrong also testosterone is
very powerful it's a controlled
substance in the United States and a lot
of transitions are now females
adolescents that are feeling
uncomfortable with their bodies and if
female takes testosterone initialism
will feel good because it's a steroid it
will make you feel good it will make you
feel more confident and I think a lot of
people you know initially take
testosterone um and they feel like it's
the right path for them because they
feel better but in the long run the
wrong sex hormone can wreak havoc on
your endless system and your body and a
lot of those defense women are now don't
pass this woman because they have deeper
voices have been permanently over it and
they are being read as trans woman even
those are biological women and it's like
they're facing all those stigmas that
come with being a trans woman and it's
also like even in the transition they
can't just move on with their lives a
lot of them because
um testosterone would change their
physical appearance so that's very sad
also some studies shows that autistic
people takes us longer to mature so
that's why it didn't it wasn't until I
hit my like late 20s and early series I
was like started waking up to reality
and just from a social standpoint I
think it takes time to realize how the
whole like masculine of feminine like
men and women interact in society where
like
um how Society functions and just making
those permanent decisions earlier on in
your timeline can really mess someone up
and takeaways are options opportunities
like my options and opportunities have
been taken away from me now it's just
like once you cut off body parts there
is no attentions back you know and if
your mental health didn't improves
that's it then you have to go within and
work on yourself and you realize you
just needed a good therapist you needed
good friends to hold you back from
permanent decisions
yeah healing doesn't come to surgeons
you have to kind of diverse in and work
on yourself and it takes time to to make
sure I realize that that's where the
healing comes from do you have any
um anger towards like did you have
friends and family that encouraged this
when you were looking at doing it yeah
honestly the transition pulled me apart
from my family that lives in America
because they didn't know better you know
they thought that you know I know what I
want and they didn't want to come across
as bigoted and they tried to be
supportive and they didn't try to push
back and they didn't know but as they
didn't I didn't know any better but I
feel angry I feel like what were you
guys thinking like my sister should grow
up with me she knew I was a man like how
did you not tell me is that like you're
a man what are you doing I don't know
they sort of was just getting like
getting your kidney fans but I know
they're getting a kidney transplant is a
joke right but they started some things
that people must you know to die because
again it's so prevalent that if you
don't access the surgeries you will you
know self-cancel but I had one new
transition I talked to on my channel she
knew seven trans women and that were
that self-cancel despite having access
to you know
scared which is like estrogen pretty
much ability to castrate themselves in
estrogen and access to surgeries and I
think a lot of times it's actual dust
disservice to people because they have
untreated mental health issues and it
gets worse over the years that's what
happens to me because the borderline and
all that if it doesn't get treated
um it gets worse you know I've lost
relationships because of that and and
worse off now than I was years ago
so if I got diagnosed properly and not
just with gender dysphoria gender
identity disorder I would have had more
time to work on myself to work on my
real issues I think it does the service
to all those young people and
children they're getting right wrote
written off as chance and get shot down
this pipeline when they possibly have
other mental issues that they could get
help with and make their life better and
now that gets worse plus their physical
health could get really damaged by those
experimental surgeries there's the only
longer studies that was ever done was in
Sweden whereas they followed people and
it shows that after a sexual assignment
surgery actual self-cancellation goes up
compared to a general population nobody
showed me that study if they showed me
that study I would have never signed up
for it it's a show that side to any of
my loved ones that would have not had
that but everything that doesn't mean
they hide it they hide it yeah they hide
it and they say it's transphobic yeah do
you what do you think about
um well and the interesting thing is I
think they're like doing like gender
studies departments and like all that
stuff you know know what they do at
those universities is if you request
certain research if it doesn't go with
their agenda they won't Grant you access
to it um they do the same thing with
like women's studies like all it's like
all the same propaganda methods that
they use
um yeah they developed it in like the
early 1900s it's like it's a whole
rabbit hole if you ever look up
hershinger I think I've heard of that
first time I just want to say that if
you're going to college to get gender
studies degree and woman studies like
whatever I mean feminine is going to
kill me for that but it's like it's just
like it's a waste of money because
nowadays college is so expensive and
um I feel like it's useless to go to
college unless you're getting I have an
MBA and I feel like that was waste of
money like I didn't go to Hawaiian
school I went like two legitimate School
in Massachusetts and I feel like it was
a complex waste of time and money unless
you're getting hard science and you're
trying to become a doctor or something
like that all those like the newest IDs
even you're just better off saving the
money even me I did economics and I'm
like I did that to a porn the graduates
yeah it's like I don't even feel like it
helped me
um yeah I mean they're teaching the
graphs and like meaning minimum average
wage and like in real life you don't
really need that so
oh so do you think that parents should
be held responsible
um for that like do you have you thought
about like suing anybody like what if
um I am I am trying to like
um just you which is like in the process
okay
it sounds like it's ruined your life to
be honest it has yeah I I can't
um uh litigation are very expensive I do
have like a GoFundMe for it but
um I haven't raised as much money we're
trying to do litigation I don't know
where it's gonna go I feel pretty
confident about it but again with
litigation you just never know
um how things are gonna go I do I blame
parents I had to do Transition on my
channel as I was only 15 when she was
transitioned and then these transitioned
at 16 I believe or something like that
she was like Clear Laundry she's no
longer 18 and um her parents they just
got very is the best for them and um I
don't think they had an email list there
are definitely some parents that
transition children for attention it's
called Ten Thousand by proxy which is
like Samsung
by proxy and really devastated because
nowadays with social media you can get
attention
and there's a lot of and it's and it's
through the mothers usually it's like
because mothers are more susceptible to
propaganda I mean I wonder because I was
curious like what your experience was
having more of like a female brain
versus a male brain because I always say
like men are just a lot more logical and
a lot of times what what I see
personally and you can tell me if you
don't or if you see something else but I
see that like most of the parents that
transition their kids it's either single
mothers or women running the household
so it's like the men following the women
um it seems that Wednesday is a trans
kid in the family oftentimes there's
some kind of trauma you know I have
parents to me and oftentimes those are
you know mothers as well that are going
through the wars of also been you know
through traumas themselves in the
childhood you know and once they've
learned being from traumatized parents
that it's generational trauma oftentimes
also as a parent that also have some
cluster B personality disorders and
oftentimes they traumatize those
children whereas their parenting style
makes the children weigh some type of
way I'm not saying it's all parents
fault but there is definitely when when
you came into a transition yeah it's
like I as I did sell first question I
realized a lot of trauma came from my
parents as well they were they were less
than ideal parents
um and you know you know that's why I
blame to an extent it depends it's Case
by case basis it's hard to make a
generalization some parents definitely
feel like that is the best for their
kids and they don't dive deeper maybe
kids have been exposed to pornography
because that's words I'm happy now
because nowadays it's everywhere right
so when you're that young and you're
exposed to sexual materials that will
mess you up too and that could lead to
people wanting to x out of their biology
in terms of male and female brain I
can't I can't say that I have more
female brain without getting full on
canceled but one thing I did experience
is the way those different hormones were
sending different signals to my body so
testosterone definitely made me want to
go out and find someone no like
technical not like literally Advanced
but
um definitely hunts for some vitamin D
so men are definitely more sexual versus
when I didn't have testosterone in my
body I just wanted I wanted to Nest you
know I wanted to have a home I wanted to
have a husband to protect me and provide
for me and when I was on both hormones
through the transition I was very
confused because it's again a chicken
and egg situation I'm sure some of those
trans people you know their initially
convinced that they're opposite sex but
once they take the hormone of open it
says it's sending signals through their
body they're making them even more
convinced so that's I feel like what
happened with me as well it's definitely
some very powerful hormones and I do
feel like it's unfair that testosterone
is a controlled substance and estrogen
is not and it's just way easier to get
estrogen it's also very powerful hormone
that made me feel things that I've never
felt before taking it and for sure
there's definitely biological
differences to both sexes and um
inspired that way through centuries of
revolution
and it's not a joke achieving this
format so
um in my opinion I want I'm curious what
you think of this I really don't think
that trans surgery should be allowed I
think they should Outlaw it and I really
think that the doctors a lot of them
should go to prison because I I just
think it's I I've you know just
interviewing people like yourself I I
just think it's wrong what they're doing
do you agree with me or do you disagree
um I agree with you because after what
I've been through and after seeing other
trans women who got on the bottom
surgery you know sister's uh Transit
ones that don't want to shove their
bulge you know they don't want to go
around like trying to normalize female
penis they end up getting the most
suffering English offers the surgery
there's one other opportunity they're
taking away and we just don't have the
Sciences just not that there is no
science showing that the surgery helps I
think it's insurance fraud to be honest
I do believe it should be outlawed I do
believe people will still be getting it
but love the Thailand and all this
country is be like the last Bastion of
the surgeries I feel like in the west
the bottom surgery should be outlawed my
concern was that
um even before I was so prevalent people
were going to Backyard surgeons and
doing it illegally but then again you
know those surgeons definitely should go
to jail
um one of the surgeons that did on me I
feel like there were both of them were
unethical uh one of them got caught
posting pictures of patients on
Instagram whereas they were knocked out
on surgery and he never lost his license
he just resigned from University of
Miami Dr Christopher Saldana it's all
public knowledge you guys can Google him
yeah he was taking pictures of patients
posting her on Instagram while they were
knocked out he made racial jokes um
about Asian penis and all that was like
posted on Instagram he took a picture of
somebody having a children in them while
knocked out Anastasia and um yeah he
just resigned he's still working as a
plastic surgeon not as gender surgeon
but as a plastic surgeon still
um the first surgeons that did surgery
on me I think he's still performing
structures even though he's in his 80s
and he had a patient died during the
surgery because he's known for doing
like a lot of surges at the same time on
people even though you're not supposed
to have like 12 hours of anesthesia you
know it's not good for you he's known
for doing like a lot of soldiers at the
same time and I think that certain that
patient was also very old I think they
were in their 60s I don't know it's
public knowledge yeah Dr Sherman Lacey
was my first surgeon and literally a
patient died during the surgeries Mr I
feel like our unnecessary surgeries in a
lot of cases a lot of times as people
are trying to escape themselves because
they've been through some serious trauma
but to be honest I killed the burden of
myself but my new version that was
living as a woman quote unquote was also
traumatized by men Again by surgeons by
doctors so it's like it's compounded
trauma so now I have to not only deal
with my childhood issues but also like
all the trauma that I experience at the
hands of doctors
and I still have ongoing surgeries that
have to be done you know so I don't
collapse one day and die and I'm still
struggling with self-cancellation so
sometimes but I'm trying to stay strong
because I don't want to be lost to
history because a lot of trans women has
committed suicide and the trans men and
the trans people in general and that
have not been accounted for because
nobody has checked on me nobody knows if
I'm alive
none of the surgeons that did surgery on
me were people who gave me hormones or
therapists that gave me letters they're
not taking any studies any
accountability like what happens to
their guinea pigs once they escape the
lab and I need to speak out and other
people that are in the spotlights are
getting so much AIDS we're getting doxed
but we need to I don't want to be lost
to history and just go out without a
fight and what how does the trans
Community react to this like the the
ones that are still in it are they
supportive or no
um they're not that support it's like
it's like religion you know what I mean
so it's like if you're a Christian and
you meet somebody who's not a Christian
and living their best life and whatnot
it creates cognitive dissonance like as
people would tend to be around other
people who are pharmas our belief system
so I think trans people don't like in
general like being faced with the Trans
stories because it makes them questions
sometimes their own transition so there
are some good trans people that are like
you know the transition stories are so
valid you know they deserves a help but
for the most part we're shunned from the
community
um by a bunch of these transitions have
been boxed by a trans activists uh our
real names and everything has been
leaked which is I'm really crazy now
we're all in danger
um but the truth of the matter unless
like trans Community starts
acknowledging the transitioners and
situation is going to get worse because
when you don't have support system you
just fall into those radical circles
that are using your stories and um so it
turns like into full-on war between like
radical activists and it's not good I
feel like right now we need to escalate
the situation and be like look at the
signs that we have no more ideologies
like what does the science says and the
science says that we don't have cities
on children
so nobody should be getting castrated
um but also on the other hand you know
the right makes fun of the non-passable
trans woman that and then the trans
Community uses those non-passable cringy
trans woman to scare children to
transitioning they're like okay if you
don't castrate yourself you're gonna
look like Chinese
so there is that that's that effect you
know so kids that are feeling
disoriented they're convinced and
brainwashed that they must be you know
trans they see Game Stop like an
other cringy trans woman like Leah
Thomas and all that they're like okay I
must capture it myself so I don't get
like both shoulders and big fit and grow
six feet tall well
in a lot a lot of these movements that
are super like I would just say like
emotions led
um they're mostly women like I I was um
I guess I was surprised but then I was
not when I found out it's like 80 of
trans people are women
um yeah it's shifted because I sing a
lot of girls now so they see this you
know plastic image of woman on Instagram
everybody has big boobies big lips and
Phillips from what I've talked I've
talked I have a few D trans women
friends I think that a lot of them have
sexual trauma and also they were exposed
to pornography young and they saw you
know
uh those pornified images of women's I
feel like they could never live up to
that potential to be liked by a man and
they kind of chose to x out of their
Womanhood in a way before they even had
a chance to live long enough you know as
women they just got scared you know well
and
and you could tell me you would actually
be a good person to ask this question I
think the life of a man is a lot harder
than the life of a woman typically
um I think both sexes
the the reason I think that is I think
women and I'm curious if you had a
switch right but I think as young women
we're often given special privileges and
were often like treated a little nicer
than the guys like um they helped the
young girl more than the young boy
because they expect men to like build up
and like where like men just have this
natural inclination to help women and
women have this natural inclination to
like you know that's there's a reason we
have like The Sisterhood right so
um I think a lot of times
the women May transition and not realize
how hard life is as a man yes and there
was a spiral video recently you might
have seen where a trans man was crying
oh he's having hard times connecting
with other people that he had more
deeper conversation with women in Gmail
bathroom when he was living as a woman
yeah I agree with you I mean I mean it's
it's scary to admit it but you're right
because when I was growing up as a boy
there was just so many expectations for
me to be strong and big and be a
provider and be smart and make all the
decision and make all the right
decisions so there's a lot of
expectations and I feel like I couldn't
live up to those expectations and as
well and I'll give you an example so if
you have an awkward girl it's cute right
it's like oh like the guys kind of like
the awkward quiet girl like like if
you're awkward as a woman men don't
really care they don't really they
almost prefer it because she's talking
to less people you know but uh they're
like oh she can't talk that's perfect
effects
but as a guy but as a guy if you're
awkward it's like women don't want to
talk to you or acknowledge you really
typically you know
um and and I just think a lot of times
especially when I found out the trans
movement was mostly women turning to men
I was like they do not realize what
they're signing up for I think yeah no
you're right and um it's I've been in
this radical feminist circles because
when you just transition your support
system or conservative right when Grace
Christians and red fans and curves so a
lot of them do see that being being born
as a woman is the worst things that can
happen to you is that's how I was in
season and sometimes I'm gonna see this
video I just want to say like it's
probably some of them have a lot of
trauma as well and their ideas are
coming from traumatic plays
um and I'm not saying some of their
ideas are not right but they're extreme
you know and um as growing up as a
feminine gay man I was also targeted not
for being a blue man and for sure when I
a lot of people you know still see me as
a woman and when I go to places to open
up a doors for me you know yeah the only
day I was at a Costco and I was trying
to buy like um what was I trying to buy
some like frozen yogurt or something and
my card was glitching and the dude was
just like here like it just bought me
well even if frozen yogurt even how you
said you were bullied or it sounded like
you said you're a bullied or you had a
hard time because you were a feminine
boy if you're a masculine girl it's like
celebrated yeah so like I was a I was a
tomboy you know like growing up like I
was never into the girly stuff but it's
almost like celebrated as a girl but
it's like demonized if it's a boy yeah
even all the feminist movement right now
and like gays against rumors and all
that they're all creating like saves the
tomboys t-shirts like that's the best
seller so tomboys were always more
accepted
um I think just eggs are I've said that
before and people try to catch someone
for that but eggs are more valuable than
spam from from our evolutionary
standpoint and I think it's kind of
ingrained in society and that's why it
was like a national emergencies like
girls and women are the children are the
first ones to be saved yeah usually
that's how it should be because uh one
man could technically you know
impregnate everyone on the planet
um so sperm is cheap and from a
revolutional standpoint that's why when
I started passing
um people start treating me better
because they thought I was a woman you
know it wasn't because I was born in the
wrong body it's just the way Society
works and I feel like a lot of my
dysphoria was social this word because I
felt like I didn't belong and I need to
do all those things to be treated better
and to belong it was never something
innate that I was born with but my
gender non-conformity wasn't it I feel
like but my femininity wasn't made but I
needed more time to find myself in
society I didn't see that there is all
this like men like Jeffree stars and
stuff you know we used to just have like
Society yeah we used to just have
societies where like I could be a tomboy
and you could be a gay guy and there was
no surgery it was just okay that's the
Tomboy in the class that's the gay guy
you know and it's just like it just
seems they've taken it so far like
trying to turn women into men and men
into women and you know what's
interesting because I'm going to ask you
about female sports in a bit but I I was
an athlete I was an athlete for 16 years
so I did volleyball and it actually when
you're at the I actually think all of
sports is sort of a psyop to turn women
into men because when you get to the pro
level half of women don't even get their
periods so it's like we start to lose
like we're not supposed to work out that
hard and I I love it I'm probably still
always gonna do it so whatever but I I
think it and it raises our testosterone
so that's why you'll see so many gay
chicks in like the WNBA and like and if
you ever notice that like in basketball
and volleyball like there's a bunch of
there's a lot of gauges almost like
trans man yeah yeah no it's and it's the
same thing yeah really new grinder like
I'm like is just almost a transplant
almost I don't know she might she might
have transitioned young or something I
think I said um no I said that almost I
mean just like there is a lot of
masculine energy coming from her well
not very in particular but there is some
definitely athletes they look very yeah
yeah
um so I'm curious what is your thoughts
on um on trans you know competing in the
opposite Sports uh for sure I mean
children and trans athletes it's like
it's I think it's obvious like
um they took a certain amount of
estrogen it still they're already
developed you know Maria Thomas is how
tall like is that a long picture where
Lia is jumping and other women are
jumping like you can tell I know there's
that Meme going around jumping a bunch
of like women like xxxy your students at
me it's pretty obvious I think a lot of
um trans people have narcissism and you
know they wanted the world to revolve
around them you know a lot of times I
haven't gotten the attention early in
the childhood and I think being a trans
outlet for them is to get attention you
know I don't think they should be
competing in a biological movement
because they obviously have an advantage
except for chess you know recently trans
women have been banned from chess and
I'm like and feminists are cheering that
on and I'm like a little bit confused
because this doesn't make sense
according to feminist ideology uh well I
actually think men are smarter than
women I think we get to uh I think they
fake the IQ test I'm a radical so yeah
yeah so and I think you could kind of
see it with the chess because I'm like
do you know how much energy it takes for
us to like think because we get so
emotional and then we have to put our
emotions away and then we gotta do the
problem and solve it and then if we
can't solve it then we get frustrated
it's like our brains just don't the men
just I'm like that sounds so nice you
can just think and like solve problems
with no emotions
um yeah I can for sure test is that I
mean obviously I was born a man but
after I got castrated like I am an
accountant actually by education I hold
a CPA license
but I I can't do masks anymore I used to
be really good at maths and no yeah no
I'm serious and I just like but I think
part of it is because there's some
studies that I've seen that change like
your brain yeah male brain when you
don't have enough testosterone and um
for sure there is definitely um I think
are there some women that are smarter
than average men yes
yes
but when it comes to chess I don't know
it's just so strange to me I think
according to your notion it makes sense
that trans women were banned but it's
weird when radical feminist cheers that
on because it's not a physical sport
right if you're saying that girls are on
average as smart as boys then they
shouldn't be uh sex division in chess
periods well I just think feminists well
pick your poison
yeah well I just think feminists like
want to believe that women are more
special and important than we are yeah
again I'm a radical so just you know
um well they are egg wise you know
because as we talked earlier yeah that
sounds more special
yeah I just met like in society like
they want all these special privileges
so they want like spec to be given
special treatment
um over men I don't think it's like an
equality thing I think it's like a we
want to be better well when I started
again back to there is a lot of
expectations from both I feel like even
though a lot of feminists do feel like
women are forced to be like super
beautiful but like you said even like
average tomboys are treated better no
Beauty it's worse it's so fake men have
higher beauty standards than women women
are much like like men are attracted to
like 50 of women like that's a high
number especially with how fat we are
nowadays like 70 of us are fat they
still think half of us are hot but like
with women we only find like five
percent of men to 20 of men attractive
so like men actually have the higher
beauty standards
um I think that being on both hormones I
realized that when I had more
testosterone it was very visual you know
yeah where it says was
um not having that much testosterone
just became more I went from like oh is
that guy is really hot you're like oh is
that guy is actually really smart and
really caring yeah and can provide for
me you know so that was definitely that
switch where it went from like being
very visually deciding if I want to be
with this
to like oh against this guy to like not
paying so much attention to the way the
person looks versus how that person
makes me feel yeah no that's the that's
the thing because guys will be like she
left me for a drug dealer a criminal how
and I'm like look it they made us feel a
certain way we're not logical we just we
just I know I miss that logical part
because I started deciding was my
emotions more yeah and it's not good
when I already have borderline
personality and there are moments when I
will snap and I'm so drowned in my
emotions that I can't control what I say
or do and it gotten worse and I don't
know why it was such a good idea to
castrate somebody who was already
growing up as an emotional boy right to
magnify my I guess what would be
considered feminine qualities in society
it was just like not good I think being
on testosterone I was less emotional and
more calculated more strategic
um but women it's not all just sunshine
and rainbows you know after I started
passing I also became Target you know
for a lot of men who will say anything
to get you in bed and then they move on
so you almost become in a way of prey
um as well to certain guys who just have
agenda to inseminate as many women as
possible you know and once they find out
that you know I don't have a productive
system I'm not that interesting or they
teach us experiments so there's
definitely some downside as well to um
to both sexes I would say there's
advantages and disadvantages you know
for sure being a woman you have someone
I feel like you have some advantages
feminists will not agree uh passing as a
woman definitely people treat me better
as I said in certain ways but also again
have to watch out for a lot of men who
didn't have the best intentions so
what is dating like as a trans you said
you're in a relationship yeah I'm in a
relationship right now which I'm really
happy that I was um so my dating life
was actually better before the surgery
because once you have the surgery you're
putting this Purgatory where
um what do we call some Chasers men that
are super attracted to like trying to
provoke trans woman no longer want you
because you don't want you know well
they claim to be straight but but
they're not you know it's all about the
deck and they're really gay and bisexual
men technically once you have the
surgery again it puts me in this weird
situation where I was convinced that I
was a woman but a lot of men that dated
me didn't want me once they found out
that I was not a biological woman and it
just created more rejections I was
getting rejected a lot turned down
um so that actually made my mental
health worse I just thought less again
you know so I went from being a possible
I guess somewhat pass possible trans
woman that Chasers wanted and bisexual
men wanted to being placed in a strange
place where where Chasers don't want me
anymore and neither do straight men
because they want a woman they'll take a
tomboys that doesn't wear makeups that's
awkward over somebody like me who I
guess it's more traditional beauty
standards but is not a woman you know
and that's another thing is that like
um I also felt like despite what people
said oh you look so beautiful I still
felt less you know I felt over time as I
realizing that I will never be like
other woman because I'm not no matter
how many surgeries I got men will still
not want me because I'm not a biological
woman you know and it just makes things
worse
um my partners that I had before
transitioning he was in my life he was
more like a father figure to me and I
loved him but then
um transition made me feel like I needed
to go out and find men's I will affirm
like that Womanhood you know and that
created this vicious cycle of constant
rejections and seeking affirmation I
think being a trans is very difficult
because you're constantly looking for
approval from the outside world and it
creates more cringy situations that I
got myself into
looking back at it it did not help me to
grow better and stronger it actually did
more damage to my confidence
um to myself works I felt just like a
discounted woman in a way like a dollar
store version of a real woman it's just
not a good place to be Sanchez told all
that I was able to uh find you know I
never left my previous husband because
he was like a family to me even though I
transitions I I just love him no matter
what our love Transit transcended like
sex and gender situation he actually
passed away recently at the beginning of
this year he was 81.
[Music]
um
so he passed away and I still miss him
but I still have
um a partner as that I met three years
ago and um right before meeting I told
him that I was a man and he accepted me
and we're still together and we love
each other and our sex life could have
been better if my surgeries never
happened yes but oh well
um because again I guess she holds his
Darkness I just want to live like except
people with a message of hope that you
can you can still find love and once you
find love it does heal a lot of your
traumas it does and when you find
somebody you love and you're together or
sometimes you forget your opinions and
I'm just very lucky but the truth of the
matter is that at the time the same time
my children partner recorded me another
guy accorded me and he did not know was
that I was a man and then
um he was okay with it and he said that
I love you no matter what you are a guy
or a good girl but he was still not over
his ex who was um biological woman and I
was always felt like inferior you know
and I felt like I did not deserve to be
in that relationship I ended up losing
that partner and that really broke my
heart
and I'm still getting over it three
years later being pulley polaramers it's
like you love multiple people I think
it's common for men I think now it also
shows
because historically you know a lot of
men had multiple wives
and I think I'm just like a gay version
of that um but now I don't want to be
any more in polar Amber's relationship
and more and more as I'm healing I
realize my programmer came from actual
place of trauma because I've had
abandonment issues I feel like the more
people love me the less likely that I'll
be alone but after my husband passed
away I lived alone for a while I
realized that I couldn't be alone and
it's okay and I kind of overcame my
fears of being alone and I started
healing and I realized I don't need to
have multiple partners to feel the love
it's actually easier to just be with one
partner
um I realized that no matter what you're
not gonna find hundred percent in one
person and I'm also not 100 and I think
part of me also felt like because I was
pretty much mutilated by the surgeries I
feel like I couldn't it wasn't fair for
you know and to be in relationship and
just tie down one person I feel like a
special story guys I felt like he needed
I told him like you can be with your ex
as well because
um I can't give you you know vaginal sex
and you're a straight guy but he's still
like
um I guess at the end of the day came
down that he wanted 100 of me and I
couldn't give him 100 of myself because
I was in a relationship with two other
people and insan he ended up going back
to his partner and that's a biological
woman and I hope so happy and now I'm
working on my traumas and trying to
focus on my relationship and honestly I
don't think I want to date anymore I
don't because it's it's really cringy
yeah it seems like it's a lot harder
yeah yeah well for me it's extra
challenging especially being a public
person you could relate to that now that
like you're online people judge debates
on your political views based on things
you've said online it's hard and uh
where people want to date you for clouds
so you just don't know what people's
obsessions are
yeah so dating is hard regardless and I
think for me it's extra challenges I'm
in this weird space
so I think right now the best thing for
me is just to be monogamous and focus on
my current partner and that's where I'm
at I don't end the other trans woman
posted or pre-op that are trying to date
it's hard dating is hard and I think
dating apps made dating like a game and
people are constantly looking for a
dopamine rush and we'll always have
those feelings that grass is greener on
the other side but it's not it's
anything that's the formal feeling that
you're missing out by being in one
relationship I think it's just an hour
ahead
well I really do appreciate you coming
forward about this stuff I know it's
probably not you know easy I know the
internet's like insane
um yeah it is hard but if people want to
support your GoFundMe where can they
find it uh it's on description of my
YouTube channel and my Twitter
um it's for my legal expenses because
you know it's expensive how much are you
trying to raise
um I don't know I honestly I need some
helps I don't like setting goals so
whatever guys people want to give it's
fine
how much does it cost to sue them or do
what you're trying to do legally I know
you can't say but I can't say like if
this is cut out I can say but I don't
want it to be like public okay yeah but
um even the
um expert witness I was like 13 000 wow
so it's a big yeah okay yeah
my my lawyer she was nice you know so
she took her on contingency but just the
expert witness Alone
um it was like thirteen thousand dollars
and filing fees I think couple of
thousand dollars but again it all
depends how the case goes so I'm hoping
that
um the institution what is it called and
like I'm so brain fog defendant
plaintiff which one is which so I hope
the other side you know as I acknowledge
or have been hard because fighting this
it's kind of arrogant you know it's
saying they've ruined your life like I
can't even the stuff you're talking
about I'm like they someone deserves to
pay yeah but again sometimes just
because something is morally wrong
doesn't mean it's illegal you know
anything again you just don't know how
the law system works like I'm not a
lawyer so I don't understand also need
to create details in my in my head I've
been 100 harm like I know that I've been
harmed whether the other side or Drew
you're gonna decide it's a way I don't
know you know when things go in front of
the jury because of the way I present
you know I'm wondering like where we're
going to go to the jewelry you know yeah
I'm confident in my case but you just
never know anything it would be arrogant
to see the things that right
um I I know 100 how it's going to pan
out I'm hoping that
um Drew will say that I've been harmed
well that's all I'm hoping for well
thank you for but even before that I
hope that the other side acknowledges
that they've harmed me yeah they should
um well thank you so much for coming on
the channel today
um where can they also find you on
YouTube it's under
um yeah shape shifters Google ship
shifter
um if that doesn't come on just Shape
Shifter d-trans on Twitter I'm shifter
of shapes or shape sometimes I'm just
real shape there's singular shades of
them shapes and I'm under his Adam or
social media platforms
um I I went to a festival and I realized
that social media was toxic and try not
to post as much I'm trying to live in
real life I realized that I never wanted
fame or anything like that
um I'm just but I still post once in a
while and keep people updated about my
life thank you so much for giving me a
platform
um I came into this without preconceived
notions you seem like a sweet person I
don't know so much hate the words you're
comparative online like a very mind
caring person
and I think people should start taking
people as individuals regardless of
their views black and white thinking has
done a lot of damage to me part of it is
like being borderline and I was just you
guys do things but I used to think since
I used to see things black and white and
encourage people to not see things black
and white and I'm saying somebody is a
demon 100 and somebody's an angel 100 so
and talking to you just solidified My
Views are that people should be taking
as individuals and not be judged by a
few things they said or done you know
well thank you I appreciate that thank
you for coming on I it actually it makes
me so sad listening to like what I just
think it's so wrong I think it's so
wrong what they're doing
um but stories like yours really do
bring light to stuff and I really hope
it deters
people that are thinking about that
surgery from the future because we can't
we can't change what's happened but at
least maybe some people could see this
and make a different choice
um okay guys make sure you go subscribe
um to ShapeShifter on YouTube and
seriously if you guys could donate to
the GoFundMe I really do think that
people should be prosecuted for this and
people that yeah I really think there
needs to be some sort of class action
lawsuit because they are not honest with
about the surgeries at all it's actually
so crazy
um make sure you like the video on your
way out and subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell and we'll
talk to you next time